there was a move a few years ago to
develop so called binary chemical
weapons
these are bombs or presumably other
munitions shells in which two chemicals
would be stalled and only after you
fired the weapon would they combine and
react to make the nerve agent in the
case of VX one of the reagents was a
molecule like this one here on the table
which contained carbon oxygen phosphorus
and nitrogen but this compound here is
called QL mass and that's not
particularly nasty substance and the
other reagent was solid sulfur so in the
middle of the bomb was a cylinder of
stainless steel filled with sulfur when
we take elemental sulfur if we heat
these two together it over 70 odd 70 or
80 degrees this initially reacts with
phosphorous the sulfur to make this bond
here and then this group migrates down
here and that happens at a fairly rapid
process so the idea was to have
elemental sulfur which is just a nice
yellow powder and this other substance
QL and within the actual missile whose
were called binary missiles or binary
bombs the chemical reaction would occur
to make the very nasty nerve agent when
the bomb was launched an electric motor
cut open the stainless steel cylinder
the sulfur and the other chemical
started reacting and by the time the
bomb landed were all being well were all
being badly depending your point of view
the VX was made and that of course made
the bomb much easier to assemble with
much less risk of anyone being killed in
making the bomb itself and also it meant
that if you had to dismantle these and
get rid of them then it was also a much
easier process
to do that the problem was that it
wasn't terribly successful because
chemical reactions depend on temperature
the rate of the reaction and the
temperature of the bomb was not
necessarily constant and so the rate of
the reaction was not always the same
between launching it and hitting the
target fortunately most of the binary
chemical weapons have now been abandoned
I think it's important to remember that
chemical weapons were first invented or
at least promoted by the German chemist
Fritz Harbor and it has turned out that
his chemical weapons have actually been
quite useful in the treatment of cancer
so although the development of decent
weapons has been terrible there have
been some positive outcomes but now with
the destruction of most of the chemical
weapons and hopefully soon all the
important thing is to eliminate the
precursor compounds the ones which could
be used to make them from normal
industrial chemistry so that industrial
chemistry core processes do not use
chemicals which could be diverted to
making nerve gases or other chemical
weapons and I'm pleased to say that the
OPCW is making considerable progress
with this and green chemistry is helping
to eliminate these dangerous compounds
that this would burst twice as much as a
single bubble but you see is more or
less the same so you can't always
predict what's going to happen